حسنًا ، فقط لتوضيح هذا
الصباح ، لا توجد تقارير وفقًا
لشبكة CNN عن أي مشاهدات للأجانب ، شكرًا
50 لماذا أشكركم على توضيح الأمر
على الرغم من وجود
إقبال جيد على حدث الأمس الذي طال انتظاره
وكان أطفالي
يشاهدون هذا  لقد أرادوا معرفة
ما سيحدث ، فنحن نتحدث عن
ألفي شخص تدفقوا على ولاية نيفادا
بعد مكالمة على Facebook لاقتحام المنطقة
51 لكن مائتين منهم وصلوا
إلى البوابة الرئيسية ولكن من الواضح أن هذا
عدد أقل بكثير من  ما يقرب من
مليوني شخص تعهدوا بمداهمة
منشأة القوات الجوية الأمريكية في
نيفادا ، لا يمكنك الوثوق في الأشخاص الذين
ظلوا وفقًا لكلمتهم ولا يمكنهم الوصول
إلى مليوني شخص قالوا إنهم سيكونون هناك على
بعد مائتي متر من البوابة.  صحيح ،
لذلك يقول العمدة المحلي إنه
تم القبض على شخصين بسبب قضايا بسيطة بما في ذلك
اعتقالات تتعلق بالكحول وآخر
بسبب التعرض غير اللائق ، قال العمدة إن
هناك أيضًا حادث انقلاب مع
إصابات لـ  الصور التي نحصل عليها
من المنطقة هي أحدث
الصور ، نعم ، لكن ما رأيك في
كل هذه الهستيريا التي كانت
تساؤلات حول المنطقة 51 من
الواضح لبعض الوقت ولكن يبدو أن هذه
المجموعة لم تبدأ  نظرًا لأن
مزحة لم تأت حقًا وأن
هذا الوعد أو التوقع صحيح ، فهذا
يوضح لك بالطبع بعض مخاطر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
وأنا أفهم حتى أن
منظم تلك الصفحة كان في الواقع يتوسل
للناس ، من فضلك لا تذهب في الواقع  هذا
كما تعلمون وحتى ابنتي البالغة من العمر اثني عشر
عامًا سألتني عنها وقالت
إنها شيءهم هو أنهم لا يستطيعون إيقاف
كل هذا الذي قلته في الواقع إنهم يستطيعون
ذلك وهم سعداء جدًا لأنهم تحولوا إلى سلام أكثر أو
أقل و  أنت تعرف المنطقة 51
بالطبع ، فإن أفضل
قاعدة عسكرية سرية معروفة أعتقد في العالم
ربما يُزعم أنها تحتوي على جميع أنواع
الأشياء هناك ، لكنني أعتقد بدون
معرفة أي معرفة بنفسي ، لكنني
بالطبع سأكون مجرد قاعدة سرية تقوم
بكل شيء.  inds من البرامج السرية هناك